almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it okay I want
to talk now about this issue of churches
at the top of the show I talked to you
about how the corona virus pandemic in
the United States is now a culture war
it's not really a fight for the best
ideas about how to deal with the virus
while taking care of the economy that
would be the right thing to do it's
merely a cultural war now thanks to the
Trump administration thanks to Trump's
fixation on opening churches and opening
them right away
we also now have to talk a little bit
more specifically about the houses of
worship component but I just want to
recontextualize
the church's thing is one piece of the
broader culture war that coronavirus is
now about it's not about public health
let's talk about the legal element of
the church openings Donald Trump said
late last week governor's must must must
at his Direction designate houses of
worship as essential organizations so
that they are allowed to reopen in
places where they have been closed and
Donald Trump even said if governors
don't determine that churches are
essential I will override governor's and
make sure that churches are deemed
essential let's look at this this is
from a press briefing late last week
Trump bailed without taking any
questions after saying the following I
know them well they love their
congregations they love their people
they don't want anything bad to happen
to them or to anybody else the governors
need to do the right thing and allow
these very important essential places of
faith to open right now for this weekend
if they don't do it I will override the
governor's
in America we need more prayer not less
thank you very much thank you so there
are multiple layers to this first is the
question our houses of worship really
essential okay now I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be exceedingly fair on this issue
houses of worship are not essential to
the economy houses of worship are not
essential to public health and they are
not essential to life you don't need
churches like you need a grocery store
because without food you die
but I understand culturally that
churches are seen as essential by
religious folks I don't see it that way
but I know many people do that's why
this is the perfect issue for Trump to
focus on in order to wage coronavirus as
a cultural war its perspective if you
think that the most important thing for
Humanity is making sure that you are
praying in the right place and that your
religion is what's holding society
together you're going to be difficult to
convince that churches aren't essential
and that's why this is the perfect way
for Trump to wage coronavirus as a
cultural war then we have the public
health component if restaurants can't
yet be open to dine in how do you
justify churches being open you can dine
in at a restaurant much more safely and
in much less time than you can go to a
church on the average you can social
distance theoretically in a restaurant
and you can social distance
theoretically in a church but you can
get in and out of a restaurant very
quickly compared to how long people tend
to be in churches restaurants at full
capacity sometimes only accommodate 15
20 or 25 people small restaurants I'm
talking about churches are almost always
at least 50 people sometimes hundreds
sometimes thousands sometimes tens of
thousands at these mega churches we know
of churches being super spreaders where
they have one service and a ton of
people end up infected because of one
person so from a public health
perspective there is no way that you can
defend churches being open when
restaurants are still closed for dining
lastly and maybe most importantly let's
focus on the legal Trump says he will Oh
ride governor's he can't do it he does
not have that authority it doesn't
actually matter by the way that he can't
do it and I'm gonna tell you why in a
second but from a legal perspective
Trump often talks about federalism
federalism just means a system with a
federal government and also subsequent
either state or provincial government
that's all that means state or
provincial governments in the United
States it is outlined in the Tenth
Amendment and the Tenth Amendment lays
out the default power dynamics between
state and federal government where it
says quote the powers not delegated to
the United States by the Constitution
nor prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the States respectively or
to the people so in other words if there
is some action or power that the
Constitution or Bill of Rights don't
specifically say the federal government
has power over this and the Constitution
and Bill of Rights don't ban states from
having power over that the default is
states decide about that issue
designation of churches as essential or
non-essential is not a power given to
the federal government and it is not a
power from which states are restricted
thus federalism and the Tenth Amendment
confirm that Trump has no authority
whatsoever
full-stop black and white period to
determine what types of entities are
essential from the perspective of states
that is really the the analysis that's
required we don't need to go further now
to finish this up it doesn't actually
matter politically that Trump has no
authority to force governor's to say
churches are essential because by merely
saying this donald trump has already
virtue signaled he has called for
churches to be designated as essential
he has claimed that we hope he will
override governor's that's really all
that matters if you are at rumpus from a
section of the religious Trump voters
you don't care that he won't actually
override governor's you don't care that
he can't override governor's he has said
what he needed to say he says he wants
to override governor's
and that he believes churches should
open right away that's it
it's virtue siglent signaling at its
worst the right is quick to criticize
virtue signaling when they see it from
the left this is absolutely the worst of
the worst virtue signaling signaling
lastly what Trump could do or what he
could try is to withhold money from
States if they don't do what he wants it
would be sick it would be immoral I
don't know whether it would be legal but
Trump has already threatened Michigan
and Nevada about withholding money if
they do vote-by-mail that he could
absolutely threaten whether he would do
it whether he could do it is a further
question to which we don't have an
answer right now we're gonna continue
covering this story on the show's
Instagram at David Pakman show
also I am having a rabbit Fiasco in my
backyard I'm going to talk about it on
today's bonus show but you can also
follow the the craziness on my personal
Instagram at David Pakman plus on my
personal Instagram the most popular post
I've ever made to Instagram it's me
holding a puppy over the weekend just me
holding a puppy nothing else and it is
exploding on my Instagram page follow me
at David Pakman quick break much more
coming up